hey jalen
how did you wrap your head around the
news today with how the ruling was made
with brianna taylor's killing and
how did you try to handle those emotions
zone that you also had a game to play
i mean it's tough to be honest i
i wasn't surprised by the verdict
this it is you know
it's tough um
it's tough it's hard to gather the words
but i wasn't surprised
i think that you know this society
you know the way it was you know built
in the way
the intentions was to never protect and
serve
you know people of color initially so
when they were gearing up for
you know what was about to happen i knew
that the wrong decision was probably
being made but
it doesn't surprise me it doesn't
surprise me at all
until we dismantle recreate or
you know change this system that we have
it's going to continue to
have victims you know like rihanna
taylor and others that
fall victim to oppression it was tough
getting
emotionally ready you know for a game
but to be honest i wasn't surprised
and we just fell short that was it
hey bam uh how did you process the news
today with
brianna taylor verdict and how did you
try to handle
those emotions uh with playing a game
tonight
you know i kind of just try to channel
my anger towards the game
you know it's crazy that somebody kills
somebody and
he gets the same the same charge as
somebody
you know that uses an unauthorized
unauthorized credit card
right i don't think people really
understand
or or or understand like
she's she's dead somebody killed her
you know like at the end of the day
you you need justice for that like uh
all the other stuff you need justice for
her right you know
giving a guy what was it one time
um endangerment uh yeah
yeah like that's the same thing as
somebody using an unauthorized credit
card like
that's crazy to think about but uh we're
gonna keep fighting for justice for
and you know um
it it's bigger than just basketball but
getting to share
and getting to talk about it in the
media on tv
you know i feel like that brings
awareness to everybody in the world
everybody wants to watch the eastern
finals the western finals
so uh just keep being on tv and just
keep bringing awareness
and we're gonna keep trying to make a
difference
given that today did you feel like the
game today was kind of a safe haven
sanctuary or
was it i guess the other way
i mean when you hear news like that
you know you kind of you kind of got to
force your anger towards
what you're doing at the moment so you
know all of us tried to transfer our
anger to
the basketball game you know and i feel
like this one was for her
and uh you know it's uh
this is this is crazy where we live in
man and the decisions that some people
are making
hey jimmy back to the verdict with uh
brianna taylor and
as you were wrapping your head around
all that how
how did you deal with the emotions
knowing that you also
had a game tonight uh obviously there's
there's always a lot of emotion that
goes on
and you never actually like don't think
about it
because it's it's always much bigger
than a sport
it's almost much bigger than basketball
because that could be anybody that could
be me that could be
any african american so when you look at
it like that
um for me um it's always on my heart
because i just think it's some some bull
crap
and going into the game you do got to
compete but at the end of the day
i mean we're people first not just
athletes
hey jason how did you uh process the
news today
with the verdict on brianna taylor
killing and how did you
deal with just all the emotions with
that you know knowing you had a game
tonight as well
uh it's frustrating um
you know i kind of felt like we knew we
knew what was going to happen
and then it's still you know still when
it when it happens
you know it's sad you know it's
frustrating
it's been 194 days
and you know still still no justice
still
still having to fight for the same thing
um
and it was just a lot to process
um it's a tough day tough day for all of
us